Speaker 1: Well, we have another disastrous
example of the repercussions of these horrifying
anti-abortion laws, many of which were triggered
into existence by the Supreme Court overturning
Roe v Wade. We go to Texas. In Texas. A
YouTuber was forced to carry her dead fetus
for two weeks after a miscarriage due
to the anti-abortion law. The same
surgical procedure used to treat a miscarriage
is also used for terminating pregnancies.
The new Texas anti-abortion laws have doctors
nervous to perform procedures for miscarriages,
forcing this woman to carry her dead fetus
in her womb for two weeks. Another example,
we've now seen women going without emergency
care. We've seen women going without cancer care.
And now women forced to have their dead
fetus in the womb for weeks due to these
anti-abortion laws. And we're supposed to
believe this is all pro-life. Beauty YouTuber
forced to carry dead fetus for two weeks after
miscarriage due to abortion ban. I get so angry
that I was treated this way because of laws
that were passed by men who have never been
pregnant and never will be, says Marlene
Estell, founder of Makeup Geek Cosmetics.
Marlene Estell recently spoke to CNN about her
gut wrenching miscarriage and how she was forced
to carry her dead fetus for two weeks. When a
doctor refused to provide medical intervention
due to the Texas abortion law, Stella's a
beauty YouTuber and founder of the cosmetics
company Makeup Geek. She initially explained
in a video last year she and her husband were
thrilled to learn of the pregnancy, noting that
an ultrasound at seven weeks was normal. However,
another ultrasound two weeks later revealed
Stella suffered a pregnancy loss. The doctor
says there's no heartbeat. There's no viable
pregnancy. Following the news, she asked for
a DNC, which is a surgery to remove the fetus,
also used to abort a living fetus. This was not
a living fetus in order to avoid infection
or long term health issues, the doctor said.
Because of the new law that's passed here,
you have to schedule another ultrasound to
verify that this pregnancy is not valid. Before
we can give you any sort of medical intervention,
Dr. Lillian SHAPIRO, an Atlanta based OB-GYN,
said to CNN. Carrying a dead fetus can quickly
become dangerous for the mother. Right. But
they're pro-life guys. They're all pro-life.
So consider this situation. Imagine how horrendous
this is. It's not just psychologically disastrous.
Walking around with parts of a dead fetus inside
you that you're not allowed to have treated the
psychological impact. But it's also physically
extremely dangerous. And these women are being
is it too much to say they're being tortured by
Republican law? Doesn't seem like too much to
say to me. She wanted to carry this pregnancy
to term and deliver it. She didn't. You know,
the right loves to have this almost at this
point, cliche, borderline satirical view of
how women decide to get an abortion. Well, it's
month seven. It's month eight. It's month nine.
I don't know. I guess I don't want it. Give me an
abortion, please. That that's an absurd fantasy.
But this is not even someone who didn't want the
pregnancy. This is someone who did. She wanted
to carry the pregnancy to term and deliver.
She miscarried and she was denied treatment
because the treatment is the same as that for
surgical abortions. This situation, ectopic
pregnancy, we're also seeing it's like the entire
political party never even took basic biology in
high school. So we have you know, at this point,
we're two weeks in, guys, since I told you.
Doctors are sounding the alarm and saying they may
be denying treatment to women for fear of being
prosecuted, for fear of not only law enforcement,
but politicians coming after them. And when I
did that first story, I got emails from people
saying, David, you're dealing in hypotheticals.
David None of these things are happening. The
hypothetical about a 12 year old pregnant girl.
It's merely hypothetical. And then we got a ten
year old pregnant girl who had to leave Ohio and
go to Indiana to get an abortion. Oh, well, now
the issue's different. It's a fake story. Oh,
no. But the alleged rapist is an undocumented
aliens. So now it's a real story. But that's
the only important part. Pathetic. And here.
Same thing. Oh, no. Just because a group
of doctors warned that this might happen
doesn't mean it's happening. Well, now it is.
Now it is. Here is a specific woman. Who was told,
yes, the fetus has died, but because of the law,
the anti-abortion law. You've got to walk around
for two weeks this way before we can do anything,
and there's going to be more of it. And the next
layer in this is this is getting so absurd that
even the Republicans can't defend it. So the new
thing they're doing is they're playing semantic
games. And the semantic games that they're playing
is they're saying, well, this procedure done when
there has already been a miscarriage is not
technically an abortion. And they're trying
to hide behind that as if this isn't the
natural effect of the law that they passed,
which, of course, it is horrifying, pathetic
and extremely damaging to the women physically
and psychologically and to their families. It's
not just about the women. Um, what will we have
for you tomorrow? I don't even want to know.
Quite frankly, I'm sure it'll be horrible.